[Music]
thanks cheers
hi there my name is bradley and welcome
to some sub a channel about how to
survive in the online oh
right uh should we try that again hello
my name is bradley and welcome to some
sub a channel about how to survive in
the online jungle um excuse me could you
help me my phone's broken i really need
to call my little sister she's around
here somewhere but could i use your
phone for a minute maybe of course
not
but why would i reject such a polite
request from someone so lovely well the
truth is even such a small token of
chivalry can have massive implications
when it comes to the loss of your money
your time and even your freedom today
i'm actually going to demonstrate how
dangerous it can be to let your phone
fall into the wrong hands
[Music]
admit it you're probably quite protected
with your phone on average we actually
touch our smartphone screen 70 to 150
times per day something like low battery
slow internet or no wi-fi this can all
cause some serious problems in the
current day and age
you might have heard of this term
nomophobia but it's the fear of being
left without a phone and many people
actually suffer from it god please help
me i promise i'll be a good person i'll
although be nice to my mom i'll quit
vaping i'll go to church in fact
statistics suggest that this fear grips
50 to 70 of europe's inhabitants if
seeing your phone battery dwindling down
to empty gives you angst you may need to
see a doctor now because of this we can
easily empathize with somebody who's
lost their phone or maybe they can't
access it
but it's this empathy that scammers are
able to take advantage of can you help
me my my phone's broken and i really
need to call my little sister yeah sure
let me just unlock it for you
one second yeah thank you
so my innate british chivalry has just
played a cruel joke on me i didn't ask
this girl for the number she wanted to
call but rather i just gave her an
unlocked smartphone it doesn't really
bother me that she might be calling a
premium number that'll cost me an arm
and a leg and it's because most mobile
operators actually have been allowing
users to block paid numbers like
nine zero zero for almost a decade and
it wouldn't work calling mexico or india
from my phone i've already blocked those
numbers long ago and therefore i'm not
really afraid of the more ancient
variants of fraud but take a closer look
at what our girl is doing before dialing
a regular phone number she enters some
additional numbers and asterisks now
these are called ussd commands
they're there to basically manage the
services of the mobile operator it's a
bit like sending an sms only they allow
fewer characters and they're free
specifically this command could be used
to forward calls from my number to
another phone and scammers use this
technique when they want to intercept
important calls imagine that you've got
a small online store and customers
frequently call you and give their say
bank details over the phone i mean a
scammer could quite easily intercept
such a call and you can also bypass
two-factor authentication this way some
services don't send sms's but rather ask
you to enter the last digits of the
phone number that called you and finally
my bank actually allows me to find out
the current balance of my account using
these very ussd commands a couple of
seconds and the girl knows whether i'm
rich or not not bad right now it's
pretty easy to protect yourself against
such situations just make sure to ask
them for the number dial it in yourself
and then lock the screen i recommend
actually finding out in advance which
ussd commands your operator supports
[Music]
it's nice when someone asks your phone
number after a first date but you're
quite unlikely to give it out to a
person that you've just met at least i
really hope so the mobile phone number
has actually become universal identifier
it's connected to
say our google accounts our facebook
accounts and also our whatsapp profiles
we now use a phone to verify our density
more often than say we use a social
security number or a national insurance
number maybe a driver's license or a
passport it's that much more valuable
and because of this your personal data
has long been a marketable commodity on
the dark net but why buy something you
can get for free without even asking
directly for it look our charming
fraudster is just calling her own phone
that's all
but she has my number in her hands in a
few seconds she can find out my full
name my address information about my
parents you just need to enter a number
onto a site like white pages this data
is enough to bypass outdated
verification systems for example to
answer security questions for password
recovery in addition for serious attacks
scammers can actually use sim swaps they
contact the mobile operator on your
behalf and report the phone missing or
stolen and at their request the operator
issues a new sim card with the same
number the scam is usually quickly
uncovered but a few hours is all it
takes to hack into an account on say
twitter or instagram and that's actually
how in 2019 hackers managed to get into
the account of jack dorsey the
co-founder and ceo of twitter excuse me
excuse me does anybody here have a phone
i can borrow i need to log into my
twitter account my phone is dead
please
all right thanks anyways
to reduce the likelihood of such an
attack
i'll always try not to disclose my phone
number in such situations if i need to
call say an unfamiliar number well i'll
use the familiar ussd commands to
disguise my number if you enter this
combination before the call your number
will remain hidden unfortunately the
service command doesn't actually erase
logs from the mobile operator it
actually only hides the number from
other subscribers and the criminals well
they're well aware of this and therefore
they often try to use the phones of
random people to communicate with
accomplices let's eavesdrop on what the
girl who borrowed my phone actually said
hi it's emily
yep
aha yeah
[Music]
as usual
no not today
um how about we meet at four at
piccadilly circus
[Music]
now it's a pretty generic conversation
right there's certainly nothing criminal
going on there
well maybe think again let's listen to
the recording of that conversation
hi it's emily
do you need rocks yeah lsd again aha
yeah
um how about we meet at four at
piccadilly circus you'll be assisting in
a crime simply by doing a small favor to
a stranger now if you still decide to
allow someone to make a call from your
phone put the call on speaker and feel
free to listen to the conversation
if you have even the slightest suspicion
of the legality of what is happening
turn off your phone now of course it's
quite rude to listen into someone's
conversation but at least you don't have
to worry about spending money on lawyers
later down the line
[Music]
asking to call someone is often just an
excuse to get your hands on another
person's phone and in this case lock
screen passes help scammers the most
this is the most unreliable
authorization method lock screen
patterns have turned out to be just as
predictable as simple passwords
according to the marked logo study the
average key consists of only five nodes
three out of four people start drawing
the key from the corners of the screen
and the general direction of the
movement is usually from top to bottom
and from left to right
it's easy to see how a person moves
their fingers all over the screen than
to see the individual letters they're
typing in for a password and even if you
have a long strong password or a
biometric authorization method you're
still not safe scammers take advantage
of the fact that humans do not multitask
very well now this trick is based on an
unexpected event that will distract
attention from an unlocked smartphone
hang on 07542
no you have got to be kidding me
now it's unlikely that this kind of
turmoil will last for longer than a
minute but even so during that time you
can do a lot our charming fraudster
first of all open the photos app strange
not at all banking applications require
additional authorization so there's no
need to waste time there
moreover text documents take a long time
to read and analyze even if you only
read the headings
but useful photos can be found even with
a quick swipe
and here the attackers are interested in
well at least two different things the
most obvious and
delicate thing was your private photos
now even if you're not a hollywood star
you could easily be blackmailed with
sensitive photos but much more dangerous
are pictures of another kind photos with
passwords those associated with your
company's internal network your home
router or network storage passwords that
are
too long to remember and we rarely use
so we prefer to keep them at hand on our
phone
because we're not going to remember them
off by heart right and photos documents
passports and bank cards are often
stored here too
do you remember how much information i
got from that laptop that i bought on
ebay
well there's much more information
stored on the smartphone nowadays this
is the fastest course of action for the
criminal attackers will not even forward
what they found over the network it's
easier to just take a picture with their
broken phone a few seconds later it's
done
protection from such actions is obvious
just don't keep sensitive information on
your phone i know you have that copy of
your passport on your phone delete it
now
[Music]
and now imagine that the attacker has
just a couple of minutes more let's say
that the girl managed to buy time by
slipping me some drugs into my coffee
but
what can be done with that extra time
smart scammers will not make large
purchases to a fake address or change
passwords to social network profiles
right all of this will take too much
time and it's also very unreliable i'd
have time to cancel the order form from
the store it'd also be very easy to
restore access to all of my social
networks so what will criminals do well
the truth is a lot of them will be
trying to infect your smartphone with
malware and the choice here is enormous
these may be programs that intercept the
passwords to applications
others will be able to give attackers
full access to your smartphone remotely
via the internet and depending on the
targets invisible spies can record all
of your conversations or track all of
your movements in real time now the
installation of such programs takes just
a few minutes and the most common way
they do this is when the attacker sends
an sms to the number of his accomplice
and in response he gets a message with a
direct download link to the desired
program
a couple of clicks and
you're done you can go to a safe place
and slowly dig up the secrets of your
conquered mobile phone now criminals can
safely plan blackmail withdraw all the
money from your account or intercept all
traffic from social networks and you're
none the wiser for them there's no need
to hurry either what can you do about
this well certain signs can actually
give away the work of malware and you
need to be aware of them for example
noticeably increased internet traffic
right fast battery discharge and maybe
the phone's high temperature when it's
just
on the desk maybe on standby if you
notice any of these symptoms back up
your data reset the phone to its factory
settings and then carefully step by step
install only the really necessary
applications you'll also be surprised
how much more space will be added even
if you didn't have any spyware installed
in the first place and now let's talk
about another type of crime even if you
really have nothing to hide criminals
can still be out for you now this is
quite scary
[Music]
up to this point we've been talking
mainly about what can be stolen from you
money your identity access rights to a
protected resource but so far we've not
said a single word about another very
real threat
the creation of fake and compromising
material
perhaps some fake nude material or maybe
faking your involvement in a crime that
is not mine that is nietzsche's now this
threat is usually greatly underestimated
by not only ordinary people but also
experts in the field of cybersecurity i
think this is due to mainly
stereotypical thinking i mean in
ordinary life forging convincing
evidence is never an easy task in the
digital reality it's quite the opposite
editing a picture or even making a fake
video well that's not difficult at all
so we're already pretty used to doubting
the digital evidence
remember one of my first videos was
actually dedicated to the creation of
such deep fakes it's really interesting
so check it out after the video
but now we're faced with the creation of
new types of compromising material
and we're gonna have to fight them in a
new way imagine that among i don't know
300 apps on your phone there's one that
can cost you your money your freedom and
your reputation
what's that it could be a messaging app
or a client of an unpopular social
network that you don't use anymore it
doesn't matter which one it is just
matters that you don't use it anymore
now attackers will actually use such
forgotten means of communication to
simulate illegal activity to correspond
on your behalf with fake accounts about
the resale of drugs the production of
pornography or forged documents
now one day
you may find that you've indicated the
accordance to drug careers several times
or harassed minors with obscene offers
all seeming to come from your phone now
the whole point of such a crime is to
fabricate convincing traces and then the
hackers will demand money for their
silence a difficult option is to try to
copy your digital fingerprints the
traces that your phone or computer
leaves behind but it's much easier to
actually use your device and therefore
if you've got a new acquaintance who
regularly shows interest in your phone
check the list of recently used
applications an unpleasant surprise
might be waiting for you i just gotta
google something real quick sure
wait what did i last google did i type i
don't know
dog dicks for some reason
thanks here you go yep sure no problem i
just wanted to google dog dicks real
quick
[Music]
now usually at the end of a video i
repeat the most important things and i
give five or six tips regarding online
safety i won't have to waste many words
today as i've only got one piece of
advice
never give your smartphone to other
people you wouldn't give a random person
your credit card the keys to your safe
or your passport would you if they asked
politely
so why aren't you afraid to let them
hold something that encompasses all of
those things your smartphone technology
nowadays is developing so fast much
faster actually than our habits are
changing
and these habits are things being taken
advantage of by experienced scammers
your job is to keep up with them think
and always look for pitfalls
remember technology simplifies our lives
sure but we have to pay for comfort with
increased security anyway my name is
bradley and my name is emily and i'd
like to offer my overt gratitude for
your open-hearted olympian odyssey on
our unorthodox omnibus of the ogre's
online swamp we'll see in the next video
[Music]